This is Jocko podcast number
16 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good
Evening Echo. Good evening.
We,
yeah,
we couldn't have been more excited.
It was a real mission.
None of us had been on a real mission
before except for our l p o r,
which is our leading petty officer
who is in the fall, first Gulf War,
and our platoon commander who was in on
the Grenada invasion and fired at the
radio tower. Those guys had this
small amount of combat experience,
but at the time,
for us,
that was a world apart from what we
had because the rest of us had zero.
This was the 90s there
was no war going on.
And so now here we were
with a real mission on deck
1994 I think I was about 23
years old. I'm in my second
seal platoon and at the time,
being in a seal platoon was literally
the sole purpose and focus of my life.
It was my whole world and that's what
most of my platoon mates were like as
well. That's, that's, that's what we were.
And this was an awesome platoon.
A great to the Arg Alpha platoon.
Yeah,
and as far as having tight friends
in a brotherhood inside of a platoon,
this was definitely one of
the best that I was ever in,
if not the best in all of us,
were just a hundred percent about being
in a seal platoon and it was the world
to us and we didn't care about,
we care about anything else really.
Not Politics, domestic politics
or international politics.
We weren't sitting around and reading
newspapers and we barely even watch the
news at this time. We were deployed
on a ship. There was no internet.
We were, we were troopers. You know,
we were errand boys as Colonel
Kurtz says in apocalypse now.
We didn't know about the policy,
but we sure as hell would enforce it.
It's w we had this mission and we
were fired up. We were, like I said,
we were on a ship and we were off the
coast of Africa when there was something
going on in one of the countries there.
And during the last deployment
that seals did on a ship.
At this time, it was some of our fellow
seals guys that we knew had gone into.
And so that was a real mission and we
kind of thought maybe this'll be our
opportunity. And probably seven
or eight months prior to this,
the battle of Mogadishu had
taken place, which is, you know,
where the movie Black Hawk down came
from. So this was, this was Africa,
this was like our chance to
get into some kind of combat.
Okay.
And we started hearing more about the
situation where they might send us,
it looked like we're going to go in and
provide some kind of security and it
looked like we're going to go in and
maybe help some Americans that were there
and get them out.
And then it looked like we might go in
and reinforce some kind of UN troops and
like a bunch of missions.
And they kind of changed as the situation
developed and in we started reading
about what was happening and what we're
going to be going to do and in what,
what the situation was
there on the ground. And I,
I didn't understand it at first.
Okay.
But there was people killing each other
by the thousands.
By the tens of thousands.
By the hundreds of thousands,
hundreds of thousands of people were
being killed. But it wasn't like, oh,
it wasn't like a war that you know,
I had read about or
I'd seen in the movies.
They weren't shooting each other with
guns or dropping bombs on each other.
They were big week using machetes,
let go like a horror movie.
Hundreds,
hundreds of thousands of
people being butchered.
And what was it all about?
It was a tribal difference that's
barely distinguishable to us.
I mean,
it's barely distinguishable for them.
The country was Rwanda
and the event came to be
known as the Rwandan genocide,
a mass murder,
primarily of Tootie tribesmen
by the rival who to clan
now war
it
or something that I can rationalize,
right?
Maybe I shouldn't be able to
do that, but I can. I mean,
there's some kind of wrong or evil in
the world that needs to be stood up
against. You know, is it fascism?
Is it tyranny? Is it terrorism?
It's forces of darkness
and they're pitted against forces of
light forces of freedom and democracy.
And as I say all the time,
war is hell and it should be a last
resort when everything else has failed.
And that being said,
war is necessary sometimes to stop evil
and sometimes it's the only way to stop
evil.
But this,
this idea here,
this situation where people
are killing each other
in a mob type scenario and they're
literally doing it like a horror movie.
I don't know how else to explain it.
It's like a horror movie that
seems to insane and to bloody,
to even be believable.
You take the worst horror movie you
can imagine with the worst plotline,
and this makes less sense.
It wouldn't even be believable if it
was a horror movie. It's too much.
It's too violent and too ruthless.
And there's too much to even
comprehend or understand
in this is,
I mean,
I hope that this is somewhere at the limit
of the evil that human
beings are capable of
you.
You hear me talk about the darkness,
the evil in the world.
Well,
this is it.
Yeah.
I'm going to the book now.
The book is called machete season.
Okay.
The killers in Rwanda speak.
During that killing season,
we rose earlier than
usual to eat lots of meat.
We went up to the soccer field at
around nine or 10 we would go off on the
attack.
Rule number one was to kill.
There was no rule number two,
it was an organization
without complications.
The judge told everyone,
everyone there that from then on we
were to do nothing but killed Tutsis.
Well,
we understood that was a final plan.
The killing of every
Tutsi without exception.
It was simply said and it
was simple to understand.
Okay.
There were some who asked if
there were any priorities.
The judge answered sternly.
There is no need to ask how to begin.
The only worthwhile plan is to start
straight ahead into the bush and right now
without hanging back behind.
Any more questions.
When you get right down to it,
it is a gross exaggeration to
say we organized ourselves.
The killings began without much planning.
The only regulation was to
keep going till the end,
maintain a satisfactory pace.
Spare no one and loot what we found
it was impossible to screw up.
And that's one of the craziest
things about this book. Again,
the book is called machete season.
It's the killers in Rwanda speak.
So this author
John Heads Fouled.
He went into the prison where these
people are now being kept to talk to them
about what they did and
it's their own words.
Okay.
In the preface to the book, just to
give you a little bit of background,
ours is appallingly an age of genocide,
but even so what happened in Rwanda in
the spring of 1994 stands out in several
ways in a tiny landlocked African country,
smaller than the state of Maryland,
some 800,000 people or hacked to death,
one by one by their neighbors.
The women,
men and children core slaughtered.
We're of the same race and shared the
same language, customs and confession.
They were Roman Catholic as those
who eagerly slaughtered them.
And I'll tell you,
I was seriously considering
not doing this podcast.
And in
this book,
Sam Harris,
acquaintance of mine who does podcasts,
who I was on his podcast,
very smart guy, brilliant
guy, and you know,
he sent me an email and said,
hey Jocko, check out this book.
And you know,
he said it's about the Rwandan genocide.
And I immediately said, hey,
you know, I was, I was there.
I mean it wasn't on the ground,
but we were there waiting to go in.
So I immediately what he was
talking about, and he's, you know,
he's basically said it's by the killers.
And so I immediately ordered it on
Amazon and as soon as I got it and I just
read it. And at first I was excited.
You don't think all this is really,
this is going to be impactful.
But as I went deeper and deeper into it,
I started saying to myself,
maybe I don't do this podcast.
Maybe I don't do it.
Because like I said, it's,
it's almost too much.
I think it is too much.
Okay.
And for that very reason,
I'm going to do it because we,
we can't,
we,
we must not deny that evil exists
and that humans can be evil.
Yeah.
And as the pre of the book continues,
our obligation,
and it is an obligation,
is to take what human beings are
capable of doing to one another.
Not spontaneously crimes of
this order on never spontaneous,
but when mobilized to think
of other human beings,
people who were their school friends,
neighbors,
coworkers and fellow parishioners
as not human beings at all.
Yeah.
And when organized for and
directed to the task of slaughter
for the issue finally is not judgment.
It is understanding
to make the effort to understand what
happened in Rwanda is a painful task that
we have no right to shirk.
It is part of being a moral adult.
So now let's listen to these
people
then that might be a stretch, but let's
listen to what these people had to say
at the beginning.
We were too fired up to think later on.
We were too used to it in our condition.
It meant nothing to us to think we were
busy cutting our neighbor's down to the
last one.
It became a goes without saying.
They had already stopped being
good neighbors of longstanding.
The ones who handed around the or Waga
can at the cabaret or Raga was like a B,
it's a banana beer.
Since they wouldn't be there anymore,
they'd become people to throw away,
so to speak.
They were no longer what they
had been and neither were we
okay.
They did not bother us and the past did
not bother us because nothing bothered
us
and so the Tutsis were driven immediately.
They tried to escape to this area
that they called the marshes,
which are outside, you know, the hills,
but people lived in the hills and
they tried to escape the mart.
Did the Tutsis tried to escape to the
marshes and another one of the murderers
says kindness too,
was forbidden in the marshes.
The marshes left no room for
exceptions to forget doubt.
We had meanness and ruthless
and the ruthlessness in
killing and a job to do and
do well.
That's all.
Some changed color from the hunting.
Their limbs were muddy.
There clothes were splattered.
Even their faces were not black in
the same way they became grayish from
everything that he had done.
A little layer of stink covered us too,
but we didn't care.
We no longer saw a human being when
we turned up a Tutsi in the swamps.
I mean a person like us sharing
similar thoughts and feelings.
The hunt was savage.
The hunters were savage.
The prey was savage.
Savitri took over the mind.
Yeah.
The more we killed the more
greediness urged us on greediness.
If left on punished,
it never lets you go.
You could see it in our eyes
bugged out by the killings.
It would even danger some.
There were those that came back in the
bloodstain shirts brandishing their
machetes, shrieking like madmen
saying they wanted to grab everything.
We had to calm them down with drinks and
soothing words because they could turn
ugly for those around them.
Man can get used to killing
if he kills on and on.
He can even become a
beast without noticing it.
Some threatened one another when they
had no more Tutsis under the machete in
their faces.
You could see the need to kill
me.
I was not scared of death in a way
I forgot it was killing live people.
I no longer thought about
either life or death,
but the blood struck terror and to
me it stank and dripped at night.
I tell myself after all,
I am a man full of blood,
all this spurting blood
will bring me catastrophe.
A curse death did not alarm me,
but that overflow of blood that yes,
a lot
in one of the things that
they talk about in the book,
please in this,
in this part of of continent,
the people, they use a machete for
everything, so they, they do there,
they cut down brush with it. They
slaughter the animals with it. They,
they cook their dinners with it.
They do everything with a machete,
so everybody's just sort of, it's, it's
there, it's there, it's there. Iphone,
right. It's their iPhone. They,
everyone has, it's their smartphone.
That's what they use for everything like
we do in America. We use a smart phone.
They use a machete for everything.
That's how they get their food.
That's how they clear out their
house to how they build. I mean,
it's everything they do.
They do with the marriage too,
so everyone's very
comfortable with a machete,
a boy with the strength in his
arms to hold the machete firmly.
If his brother or father brought him
along in the group he imitated and grew
used to killing youth,
no longer hampered him.
He became accustomed to blood
killing became an ordinary activity.
Since our elders and everyone did it,
or a young boy might even prove more at
ease with it than an experienced oldster
because deaf touched him farther away.
Given the novelty of the
circumstances and his young age,
death seemed less important to him.
He saw it as belonging
to an older generation.
He shrugged off its perils and
considered it a distraction.
It became a madness that
went on all by itself.
You raced ahead or you got out
of the way to escaping, run over,
but you followed the crowd.
The one who rushed off,
machete and hand,
he listened to nothing anymore.
He forgot everything.
First of all,
his level of intelligence doing
the same thing every day. Men,
we didn't have to think
about what we were doing.
We went out and came back
without having a single thought.
We hunted because it was the order
of the day until the day was over.
Our arms ruled our heads.
In any case,
our heads no longer had their say.
We became more and more cruel,
more and more calm,
more and more bloody.
But we did not see that we were
becoming more and more killers.
The more we cut,
the more cutting became
child's play to us for a few.
It turned into treat,
if I may say so.
That's one of the things
they do is they use some,
some words like cut and what they
mean is slaughter and murder,
but they use kind of a term
that's less drag as a euphemism.
Hmm.
At the start of the killings,
we worked fast and skimmed along because
we were eager in the middle of the
killings.
We killed casually.
We killed to keep the job going.
Some we're tired of
these blood assignments.
Others amuse themselves by torturing
Tutsis who had made them sweat day after
day.
Since I was killing often,
I began to feel it did not mean
anything to me. It gave me no pleasure.
I knew I would not be punished.
I was killing without consequences.
I adapted without a problem.
I left every morning free and
easy in a hurry to get going.
I saw that the work and the results
were good for me. That's all
during the killings.
I no longer considered anything in
particular in the Tutsi except that the
person had to be done away with.
I want to make it clear that from the
first gentleman I'd killed to the last,
I was not sorry about a single one.
Okay.
Now,
as I said,
it was difficult for to
to to tell who's who.
Right? They had the same culture.
They had the same language.
They look the same and you might be
wondering how did they know who was who?
Well, the author explains that
somewhat here and it is just,
well, I'll go to the
book after the genocide.
Many foreigners,
a wondered how the huge number of Hutu
killers recognize their tootsie victims
in the upheaval of the massacres since
Rwandans have both ethnic groups speak
the same language with no distinctive
differences live in the same places and
are not always physically recognizable
by distinctive characteristics.
The answer is simple.
The killers did not have to pick out
their victims. They knew them personally.
Everyone knows everything in the village,
so they didn't have to guess.
They didn't have to identify him by a
different skin color or by a different
facial structure or by different language.
They knew them.
A teacher and a survivor
of the marshes confirms.
Okay.
The principal and the inspector of
schools in my district participated in the
killings with nails,
studded clubs, teachers,
priests, the Burgo Master, a sub profit,
a doctor,
they all killed with their own hands.
They were pressed cotton trousers.
They had no trouble sleeping.
They traveled around and
vehicles wrong light motorcycles.
These well educated people were calm and
they rolled up their sleeves to get a
good grip on their machetes.
For someone who has spent his life
teaching the humanities as I have.
Such criminals are a fearful mystery.
So like the, the priests, the, the,
the burger master, which is
like a kind of a German name of,
uh,
of someone that's a political person,
political magistrate in a town or a
sub prefect. That's a sub prefect.
As someone that's in command,
someone of authority,
especially in the Catholic church.
So these people with their nice shirts
and nice pants were rolling up their
sleeves to get a good grip
on their machetes. At first,
the killing was obligate Tori.
Afterward we got used to it.
We became naturally cruel.
We no longer needed encouragements or
fines to kill or even orders or advice.
Discipline was relaxed because
it wasn't necessary anymore.
I don't know anyone who was
struck because he refused to kill.
I know of one case of punishment
by death, a special case, a woman.
Some people caught her to punish
her husband who had refused to kill,
but she was in fact a Tutsi
afterward.
The husband took part without whining.
In fact,
he was one of the busiest in the marshes.
So these tribal,
the though the Hutus and the Tutsis
would marry each other. I'm just like,
you know, you put human beings
living in the same village, you know,
you end up marrying somebody
from the other tribe
and if you didn't go with the system,
you are getting murdered.
In the evening we had to report to the
leader about exactly what we had killed.
Many boasted for fear of
being taunted or frowned on.
That was also a good reason
why we did not bury the bodies.
Someone suspected of faking could
guide the verifiers to the truth.
Okay.
Anyone who had the idea of not killing
for a day could get out of it, no problem.
But anyone with the idea of not killing
it all could not let on or he himself
would be killed while there's watched
voicing disagreement out loud was fatal on
the spot.
Okay.
So we don't know if people had that idea.
In the evening after the killings,
there was time for friendship and
meeting friends brought us light hearts.
We would chat about our days.
We share drinks, we ate.
We no longer counted
up what we had killed.
Yeah.
But what it was that it would bring us,
the killings had made
us gossipy and greedy.
So that's one of the things that drove
was they get to use you or kill a family.
You take whatever you want from them,
including their land,
including all their property,
everything.
Hmm.
So that's what they talk about. And
they become, they become greedy.
Okay.
And then at a certain point,
the authorities no longer had the
ability to plan or to channel.
Their orders fell on deaf ears.
The massacres had become
extraordinary beyond all reason.
The keenest ones, when they killed
the grab the possessions of the dead,
they wanted everything right away. Not
even stopping to finish off their victims.
The looting excited them so much.
They needed no advice or encouragement.
Their greed spread to those who followed,
who went crazy and turn.
We began the day by killing.
We ended the day by looting.
It was the rule to kill going out.
And Luke coming back,
we killed in teams,
but we alluded every man for himself
or in small groups of friends,
those who killed a lot
had less time to pillage.
But since they were feared,
they would catch up
because of their power.
So Hey, if I go out and kill
the most people, I don't
have that much time to loot.
That's okay cause everyone's scared of
me. Yeah. So they kind of let you, yeah.
Some killers claimed girls in the
marshes that satisfied them and made them
neglect, looting. They figured
they'd catch up the next day.
Now here's a, again, this
is going back to the,
the author does not direct quotes from,
from the killers,
but the authors kind of telling a
story about a situation that happened.
Um,
one of the murderers witnessed
the passage of armored cars.
So the international community community
likeyeah you heard me talking about the
fact that I was on a ship with seals with
marines that could have done something
here, but we didn't do
anything. I actually,
the marines went in and provided
a little tiny bit of aid.
I think they sent 30 guys in,
but it would nothing,
nothing to what did did. He had, you
know, a very minimalistic impact,
but what happened was
civilized people left
and
okay,
so they see armored cars
coming and they caused it here.
Now this is going to one of the killers
talking. They caused a big panic among,
among us who are already
roving in the streets,
heating themselves up with sudden
burst of gunfire. Some of them shouted,
the whites are here, others will
come. They have terrible weapons.
It's all over for us.
When they saw the convoy disappear in
the dust without even a little stop for
curiosity or a drink on the main street,
they celebrated with some Primus,
which is getting alcohol and shot off the
cartridges and their guns is a sign of
relief.
You could see they felt saved.
They will rid of the last stumbling block,
so to speak.
At the same time in Kigali,
which is the capitol whites were
leaving the embassies, offices,
monasteries and universities via road
convoys to neighboring countries and an
emergency airlift operating
out of the airport.
Okay.
Very few foreigners sought.
Refugee sought refuge in guarded villas,
but no foreigners were left.
And now this is again,
this is the commentary from the author,
not one foreigner, priest,
service corps, volunteer,
diplomat,
NGO worker.
None can provide a convincing reason for
this immediate and astonishing flight
during the opening hours of the killings.
In any case,
neither danger nor panic
can justify such haste.
The most telling explanation I've
heard so far comes from Claudine.
You stay a farmer and soup
and survivor on the hill.
When she says reversing our proverb,
whites do not want to see
what they cannot believe.
And they could not believe a genocide
because that is a killing that overwhelms
everyone.
Them as much as the others.
Okay.
And so they left?
No.
The thing that sparked this,
there was a, there was a leader,
so there've been,
there'd been revolutionary or right
as civil war going on and it was used,
the Rwandan civil war had been going
on and it was between the Hutu led
government and the Rwandan
Patriotic Front or the RPF.
And so the,
the RPF was largely composed of Tutsis
and a lot of them had fled to Uganda,
but now they were saying,
hey, let's go back.
And there was a bunch of pressure,
international pressure on the,
on the government,
which was led by the president
of Rwanda named Hobby Ari Mana.
So Habyarimana felt all this
pressure and so they made peace.
And then what happened was on April 6th,
1994,
an airplane that had,
um,
Habyarimana in,
it was shot down and everyone was killed,
including him. And that was it. So
the Hutu president was killed, the,
his aircraft was shot
down and that was it. Um,
and I pulled this little
paragraph here from Wikipedia.
Genocidal killings began
the following day. Soldiers,
police and militia quickly executed
key Tutsi and moderate who two leaders.
So they were just getting after it,
then erected checkpoints and
barricades and use Rwandans,
national identity identity cards
to systematically killed Tutsis.
So in the 30s,
they had implemented this system where
you would put whatever tribe you were in
because it was so hard
to tell who was who.
And they just use those
identification cards.
These forces recruited or pressured
who to civilians to arm themselves with
machetes, clubs, blunt objects
and other weapons to rape,
maim and kill their tootsie neighbors
and to destroy or steal their property.
But
one of the,
one of the major influences
on the people was radio.
It was radio.
And as leading up to this,
you had this situation where they
were broadcasting sort of I guess,
I guess it's what we call hate speech,
you know, that's what we call it only.
This was actual hate speech going to
the book in the broadcast studios of
popular radio stations,
Radio Rwanda,
the Tutsis were referred to
as cockroaches, announcers,
the two best known whom were Simon Bikini
and Contano used humorous sketches and
songs to call openly for the
destruction of the Tutsis.
One of the, one of the killers
remembers those Gen and actually this,
this guy was a, yeah, he
was one of the killers.
Those gentlemen were famous
artists and great comic virtuosos.
What they said was so cleverly put and
repeated so office often that Tutsis
themselves found them funny to listen to.
They were clamoring for the massacre
of all the cockroaches, buttoned,
amusing ways. And for the Tutsis,
those weedy words were hilarious.
So they're actually hearing
this and laughing about it.
The songs urging all Hutus to get
together to wipe out the Tutsis.
We laughed out loud at the jokes.
Okay.
And they made this who to 10 commandments,
which is basically,
it's a document.
You look it up on Wikipedia.
It's just a document that's the 10
commandments. If you marry a Tutsi woman,
she should be killed.
She's, I mean, it's brutal.
Hmm.
Absolutely brutal.
And now
this is,
yeah.
I found this piece fascinating.
Continuing to talk about the,
the radio.
And
this is,
this is a statement,
and this is interesting because we're
on a podcast and I listened to podcasts
and I've, I haven't talked about
this before, but when I was a kid,
I listened to radio shows and
I understood the power of them.
I listened to a radio show and I'll
have to look and see where it is now.
It was called the Dr Demento show.
And the Dr Demento show was this,
it was on like Sunday nights,
10 o'clock on some college
radio station in New England,
and it would just have various,
it was like a variety show, right?
And they'd have a comedic part and there'd
be like a twilight zone type thing.
But I would sit there like
we do with podcasts now,
and I'd put the head phones on and I'd
get in the zone and I would listen.
And you realize, and you realize
this, when you get into a podcast,
you realize there's a certain power to it.
There is a certain power to listening
to a person and their voice going into
your head. And there's a, there's a,
a piece about this inside the
book and it just nailed me.
It's, it's a remark made
by surge Dany who was, uh,
an SAS and he's talking
about the first Gulf War.
But what he says about radio,
and he would be obviously
saying this about podcasts now,
is that radio is far and away
the most dangerous of the media.
Yeah.
It wields a unique and terrifying power.
Once the state or an
institutional apparatus collapses,
it casts off everything that might
attenuate or sidetrack the force of words.
In a chaotic situation,
radio can prove to be the most efficient
tool of democracy as well as of
revolution or fascism because it
penetrates unhindered to the individual's
deepest core anywhere and at any moment
immediately without the necessary and
critical distance inherent in the
reading of a text or an image.
So when you listened to a podcast,
that's such a great note to explain
why radio has so much power.
You don't even have to
interpret the words. You don't
have to interpret an image.
The words are going into your head.
Mm.
And they use it.
They use it in situations like this.
And one of the killers said
ever since the plane crash,
so ever since the president was shot down,
the radio head hammered at us.
The foreigners are departing,
they had material,
the proof of what we are going to do
and they are leaving this time around.
They are showing no interest
in the fate of the Tutsis.
We witnessed that flight of the armored
cars along the road with our own eyes.
Our ears no longer heard
murmurs of repo of reproach.
For the first time ever,
we did not feel we were under the
frowning supervision of the whites.
Other encouragements followed that assured
us of unchecked freedom to complete
the task. So we thought good. It's true.
The blue helmets did nothing except
an about face to leave us alone.
And if you don't know what blue helmets
are when you're working as a United
Nations peace keeper,
they give you a blue helmet and
anybody can fill that role and he,
any nation that's part of the UN Americans
fill that role from time to time,
but any nation can do it.
So he's saying that the blue helmets did
nothing except an about face to leave
us alone.
Why would they come back before
it's all over at that signal.
Off We went.
We were certain of killing
everyone without drawing evil looks,
without getting a scolding
from a white or a priest.
We joked about it instead
of pressing our advantage.
We felt too at ease with an unfamiliar
job that had gotten off to a good start,
but time in laziness played an
ugly trick on us. Basically.
We became too sure of ourselves.
We slowed down and that
overconfidence is what did a sin.
So let's hear a little bit about the,
the psychological impact of
what's happening to the book.
Rowdy's kept on slaughtering cows after
the killings because they couldn't put
down their machetes
during the killings.
We had not one wedding, not one
baptism, not once. Soccer match.
Not One religious service like Easter.
We did not find that kind of celebration.
Interesting anymore. We did not care.
Spit for Sunday silliness.
We were dead tired from work.
We were getting greedy.
We celebrated whenever we felt like it.
We drank as much as we wanted.
Some turned into drunks.
Anyone who felt sad about someone he had
killed really had to hide his words and
his regrets for fear of being seen as
an accomplice and being treated roughly.
Sometimes drinkers went mean when they
had found no one to kill that day.
Oh, there's went mean because
they had killed too much.
You had to show them a
smiling face or watch out.
Yeah,
different personalities.
Some guys are going crazy because they're
not killing enough and some guys are
going crazy because
they're killing too much.
A youth could hide a girl he had brought
back from the marshes to have her
behind a pen or a clump of bushes,
but when he had had enough or when
tongue started wagging. In other words,
when people started talking about the
fact that he had brought one of these
girls back, he had to kill her
to avoid a serious penalty.
We had sessions with girls
who were raped in the bush.
Nobody dared protests that.
Even those who are edgy about it because
they had received blessings in church,
for example,
told themselves it would change nothing
since the girl was marked for death
anyways,
there were two kinds of rapists.
Some took the girls and use them until
the end. Even on the flight to the Congo,
they took advantage of the situation to
sleep with the prettiest Tutsis and an
exchange showed them a
little bit of consideration.
Others caught just to fool around
with for having sex and drinking.
They raped for a little while and then
handed them over to be killed right
afterward.
There were no orders from the authorities.
The two kinds,
we're free to do as they pleased.
Now we get into a
a story,
I don't know what to call it
other than a story, a travesty,
a horror
coming from one of the workers at a,
okay.
Add a little,
basically a little Christian hospital.
They surrounded the maternity hospital.
They ripped down the gates.
They simply shot up the locks.
They wore very handsome cartridge
belts of highly polished leather,
but they wanted to avoid wasting bullets.
They killed the women
with machetes and clubs.
Whenever one of the more agile girls
managed to escape in the commotion and get
out a window,
she was caught in the gardens.
When a mama had hidden her
child been underneath her,
they picked her up first,
then cut the child than
cut its mother last.
They didn't bother to cut
the nursing infants properly.
They slammed them against the walls to
save time or hurled them alive onto the
heaps of corpses.
That morning we were more
than 300 women and children.
That evening in the garden there only
five women left speared because they were
lucky to have been born.
Who too.
Now the author
goes into a statement here about,
yeah,
about a tradition in war torn areas
where you know there's some sort of
friendship or there's some,
some love that that makes people do
things that are outside the bounds of what
the norm of what the massacres are
helping the opposite side or whatever.
So, so he says this, people have,
who have lived through war often tell
wonderful stories about friendships,
incredible romances,
amazing gestures of solidarity,
comical and poignant collaborations
between protagonists and enemy camps or
humble and admirable deeds.
It all provides material
for novels, songs, films,
and evening of evenings of memories,
near Patches,
things up between you and humanity.
French and German.
Conscripts conscripts chatted across
the trencher trenches and swap tins of
potted meat.
Algerians hid French colonists
with whom they played cards.
A vici minister foiled the deportation
of a colleague with whom he had went to
school. It was the same
in Vietnam, Ireland,
Lebanon and Gola, El
Salvador, Israel, Chechnya,
in the name of passion, childhood, a clan,
elemental things like
affection or loyalty.
But here
we find not one comradery,
impulse among teammates,
not one gesture of compassion for
helpless babies at the breast.
No bond of friendship or love that
survived from a church choir or an
agricultural cooperative.
No civil disobedience in a village,
no rebellious adolescent
in a gang of budding Tufts
and not a single escape network,
although it would have been easy to
have set one up in the 40 kilometers of
uninhabited forest between the
marshes and the Burundi border.
No convoy,
no links among the herders paths,
no web of hiding places to allow
the evacuation of survivors
nothing
and it continues.
He continues to talk about really the
difference between genocide and war
in war, men are killed first because
they are the most apt to fight back.
The next targets are women liable to
help them and boys because they try to
continue the conflict and then older
men who can offer wise counsel.
But in genocide the killers track
down everyone in particular babies,
girls and women because
they represent the future.
Genocide goes beyond war because
the intention lasts forever.
It is a final intention
and again just talking about the
fact that there was no mercy,
no mercy. One of the killer says,
I do not know of a single who,
two woman who hid away a little tootsie
child to save it from the massacre of
its family,
not even a toddler wrapped in a cloth or
nursing unrecognizable to her neighbors
because of it's tender age.
Not One woman on the whole hill
cheated in the way of a rescue,
not even for a short moment of trying.
And what are the other killers said?
I did not hear many women protesting
against two seat Tutsis being raped.
The knew this work of killing fiercely
heated up the men in the marshes.
The agreed on this except of course if
the men did their dirty sex work near the
houses,
and again,
here's one of the killers talking about
the fact that they knew these people
in war you kill someone who
fights you or promises you harm
and killings of this kind.
You kill the Tutsi woman used to listen
to the radio with or the kind lady who
vote medicine plants on your wounds or
your sister who is married to a Tutsi or
even for some unlucky devils,
your own Tutsi wife and your
children by General demand.
You slaughter the woman.
Same as man.
That is the difference
which changes everything
and here's the loan story of
someone that tried to stop this.
It was close to noon on April 11th sold.
Remember this started on April
six so it's been five days.
The first day of the Tutsi
on in this particular area
is a door,
was sitting on a chair in front of his
house resting after a morning of weeding.
He was a Hutu farmer,
65 years old who had
arrived 20 years before.
Okay.
Some strapping fellows armed with
machetes came singing up the path that ran
near his house is a door called to
them and as deep old voice and lectured
demond public in front of the neighbors.
You young men are evil doers.
Turn on your heels and go your blades.
Point the way towards a
dreadful misfortune for us all.
Do not stir up disputes too
dangerous for us farmers.
Stop tormenting our neighbors
and go back to your fields.
Two killers approached him laughing
and without a word cut
him down with machetes.
Among the band was is it doors son
who according to witnesses,
neither protested nor stop
to bend over the body.
These young men went on their way singing.
Now speaking of family and I mentioned
that some of the Hutus and Tutsis work
intermarried and had mixed children and
here's sort of the standard operating
procedure for that.
This is coming from one of the killers,
a Tutsi wife.
You could try to save her.
You offered a cow to the leader and the
radio with the like to the organizers.
Then you handed out small payments of
money to those who were prowling around
your house, but that wasn't even worth
trying if you did not want to cooperate.
Meaning if you didn't want to kill a
Tutsi husband, you couldn't bargain for
he was at the head of the list.
If his wife began to argue,
she was struck right away and they
cut her husband while she watched to
discourage her.
Okay.
If she kept on,
she'd be caught herself with her children.
One or the other killers said someone
who wanted to save this Tutsi wife was
required to show great
enthusiasm in the killings.
Someone who behaved weekly or
timidly new is all over for his wife.
Grousing or idleness doomed her.
Okay,
dove,
you even complained
and they talk about,
I wonder the other killers talking about
how it was easy to kill her, the street,
the strangers.
It was much better to kill strangers and
acquaintances because acquaintances had
time to stab you with an intense
look before receiving the blows.
I look from a stranger pierce to
your mind or memory less easily,
but
there were some that obviously seem to
enjoy this.
Some amused themselves with their machetes
on the Tutsis to show off their skill
to everyone. They would swagger
around boasting later in the evening.
Some slowed down their
machetes just for punishment.
If a Tutsi you'd worn out a
pursuer in a running chase,
he could be teased with the point of
a machete. It would be nasty for him.
It was like demonstrating the bad example
except that no one was
left alive to notice.
Yeah,
and obviously when you have families,
you have children and we have children,
you have babies
and here's one of the killers talking
about the treatment of the babies,
saving the babies.
That was not practical.
They were whacked against walls and
trees or they were caught right away,
but they were killed more quickly
because of their small size and because
they're suffering was of no use.
They say that at the church they
burned the children with gasoline.
Maybe it's true,
but that was just in the first day turmoil
after that afterward.
That did not last.
In any case,
I noticed nothing more.
The babies could not understand
the why of the suffering.
It was not worth lingering over them.
Yeah,
and as I mentioned earlier,
some of the kids
were part of the killing.
And here's one of the killers talking
about that many children killed
some save, the were sickened
by it, scared of it,
but we're forced to cut by their mamas
are papa's most are completely silent
when they hear talk of the
killings even from years ago,
keeping silent blocks,
both judgment and change.
Now,
to add to the evil of all this,
to add to the, to the end,
comprehensible nature of it all, it's,
it's,
it's almost just unbelievable
nature.
But on top of all this,
these people were Christians.
They were Catholics. They were,
they were church going people
that were transformed almost
instantly into murderers.
Okay.
And here's one of those,
one of the killers talking about that
transformation that Saturday after the
plane crash was the usual choir
rehearsal day at the church.
We sang hymns in good
feeling with our Tutsi.
Are Voices still blending in the chorus
on Sunday morning we were, we returned
at the appointed hour for mass.
They did not arrive.
They had already fled into the bush in
fear of reprisals driving their goats and
cows before them.
That disappointed us greatly,
especially on a Sunday.
Anger hustled us outside the church door.
Okay.
We left the Lord and our
prayers inside to rush home.
Okay.
We changed from our Sunday best
into our work a day clothes.
We grabbed clubs and machetes.
We went straight off to kill him.
Here's another killer.
I was a deacon,
the one who made arrangements for the
Christian gatherings on the hill in the
priest absence.
It was I who conducted ordinary services
during the killings.
I chose not to pray to God.
I sense that it was not
appropriate to involve him in that
the white priest took off.
At the first skirmishes.
The black priests joined
the killers or the killed
God kept silent and the church
is stank from abandoned bodies.
Religion could not find its place
in our activity for a little while,
we were no longer ordinary Christians.
We had to forget our duties
learned in catechism class. We had,
first of all,
to obey our leaders and God only
afterward very long afterward to make
confession and penance
when the job was done
again. Aye. Aye.
Yeah.
It's just, it's, it's, I didn't know if,
if I could give this book to
bring people here to this place.
Okay.
And to me,
this part that I'm about to go through is,
yeah,
about as dark as it gets in the marshes.
You heard no children's cries,
not even murmurs.
They waited silently in the mud.
It was really something when we
uncovered a woman with a nursing,
the infant would not even whimper.
Okay.
It was miraculous,
so to speak.
Many Tutsis,
no longer to be spared.
That was how they greeted
death among themselves.
They had stopped hoping.
They knew they had no chance for mercy
and went off without a single prayer.
Okay.
They knew they were abandoned
by everything, even by God.
Okay.
They no longer spoke to him at all.
They were leaving in suffering to join
him and no longer asked him for anything.
Not Comfort, not blessing, not welcome.
They no longer prayed even to drive
away the fear of an agonizing death.
It was two astounding.
It was unnatural.
Even animals that know nothing of pity,
nothing of anguish, nothing of evil.
They cry out terribly at the
moment of the fatal blow.
That mystery drove us to many discussions.
We saw explanations for these Tutsis
who went often to death without breaking
their silence.
That could frighten us sometimes at night
because it was said that such calmness
must be a bad omen from heaven
and here's the one to the other killers
talking about that silent death from the
Tutsis
when the Tutsis were caught,
many died without a word.
In Rwanda,
people say die like a lamb and the Bible.
Okay.
Of course, in Rwanda there are no
sheep, so we have never heard their cry.
It's sometimes touched us painfully
that they awaited death. In silence
evenings we would ask over and over,
why no protest from these
people who are about to leave?
Why do the beg for mercy?
The organizers claim that the Tutsis
felt guilty for the sin of being Tutsi.
Okay.
Some kept saying they felt responsible
for the misfortunes they had brought upon
us.
Well,
I knew that was not true.
The Tutsis were not asking for anything
in those fatal moments because they no
longer believed in words.
They had no more faith in crying out
like frightened animals, for
example, howling to be heard above.
The mortal blows
and overpowering sorrow was
carrying those people away
and they felt so abandoned.
Yeah,
they did not even open their,
and while all that was happening,
where were we?
Like I said,
I mean,
I was in a seal platoon on that ship.
We were had
assets in the Marine
Corps did, like I said,
something small. They got authorization,
but it was tiny in comparison
and it was
to hear them,
to hear the killers talk about that.
Here's,
here's what one of them said.
All the important people turned
their backs on our killings,
the blue helmets, the
Belgians, the white directors,
the black presidents,
the humanitarian people and
the international cameraman,
the priests and the bishops.
And finally, even God,
did he watch what was
happening in the marshes?
Why did he not stab out our murderous
eyes with his wrath or show some small
sign of disapproval to
save more lucky ones?
A knows horrible moments
who could hear his silence?
We were abandoned by all words of rebuke.
Okay?
And I'm gonna close from
the book with this statement
from one of the survivors
before I knew a man could kill another
man because it happens all the time.
Now I know that even the person with
whom you've shared food with whom you've
slept,
even he can kill you with no trouble.
The closest neighbor can turn
out to be the most horrible.
An evil person can kill
you with his teeth.
That is what I've learned
since the genocide.
Okay?
And my eyes no longer gaze.
The same on the face of the world.
My eyes no longer gaze.
What?
What can we take away from this?
This
blogger madness?
Yeah,
we have to learn something.
We have to gain something.
But what?
What is it?
And as I tried to answer
that question for myself,
I thought about something that
I say and something that I know
and this made it even more clear
that there is evil in the world.
There is darkness and
it exists and it's real,
okay.
And it comes from us.
It's human. It is people.
We
are evil,
okay?
It wasn't a, it wasn't a monster
that murdered all those people,
those men and those women and
those children and those babies.
It wasn't an animal or some force of
nature like a tornado or a hurricane or a
tsunami,
okay.
And it wasn't Satan and it wasn't
some mysterious evil spirit.
Yeah,
it was us.
And that that is downright horrifying.
But there is a counter that,
there is a dichotomy to that,
okay?
And that is the fact that wall,
we are the evil in this world.
We are also the good,
we are the light that
counters this darkness.
And it sickens my heart to know that
we did nothing while this happened.
And I was there, I was off the coast,
I was on deployment in my platoon,
was one quick helicopter flight away.
And maybe we could have helped.
Maybe we could have saved
even just one person,
one child or one mom or one baby.
We could have made some
kind of difference.
But we didn't,
we didn't get the order.
And so we sat while this evil unfolded
and I'm ashamed of.
Yeah,
because you see,
we all have the capacity to
bring light into the world,
to counter the darkness. All of us do
in some way, maybe, maybe not directly,
maybe not face to face with evil,
but we can help.
All of us can help.
So the message I take away
from this abject horror,
to me,
it's that I need to focus,
that we need to focus on what
good we can do to help people
who can, who can we help? How can we
help get better? Who can we improve,
help improve their station in life?
What threatened person can we defend?
What oppressed person can we free?
What person,
what,
what fellow human being can we
remove from the grip of fear?
Who can we,
who can I,
who can we? What person out in the
world can we take from the darkness?
And bring into the light.
And that's
the question and the answer
that I brought away from this.
And I know that this was a heavy,
heavy book cover
and I,
like I said,
I don't just want every time that you
turn on this podcast to get crushed with
something like this,
I don't want to dwell on it.
And then I've got some good positive
books I want to look at next,
but I don't want to ignore
this kind of thing either.
Because as I've said before,
you can't appreciate the light
if you don't understand the darkness.
And as I said, this is truly
about as dark as it gets. A
little bit heavy Heiko
yeah, yeah, I'd say so.
Yeah.
I gave echo a heads up three
or four days ago and I said,
hey man,
I'm not quite sure about this one.
This is going to leave a mark.
And
I truly debated whether
or not to go forward,
you know, because there were some
people that even, or even about the,
even about the forgotten Highlander,
there were some people that said, hey,
you know, that's just too much. You know,
that's just too much and this is, this is,
this is completely beyond
that because the, the,
there is no rhyme or reason.
I mean at least you could look at a
Japanese imperial soldier and say, Hey,
he's a sick person that's doing
something for this. Cause there was,
there was nothing here.
No rhyme or reason that was
just slaughter kids and beat.
That's,
that takes it to a whole nother level and
just how they talk in detail about how
they deal with the kids.
Yeah.
Then again, to me, the,
the thing I took away from it as this
sort of personal responsibility that we
all have
to help out other humans.
And again,
I understand that everyone's
not going to be in the military,
out on the front lines, fighting
against, you know, tyranny and evil.
I understand that.
But what can you do to help out?
And I've said this since day one,
I was wondering,
one of the things I talked about
in this podcast is, you know,
I don't feel like I'm really
good at helping, you know,
people with causes and stuff like that.
I just don't feel it.
I don't feel like it's
something I'm very good at.
But this makes you rethink and say what,
what? You know, what can you do to help?
Because there's people that are suffering.
I mean obviously right now we've got,
you know, we got isis better doing
the same activities if not worse.
They just do just crucified a
priest that was just in the news.
So the evil is still there
and it is happening before our own eyes.
Okay.
It makes me,
it makes me sick
that we,
with the ability to do something about it,
we sit on the sidelines.
So hopefully we start to
move in a direction where
we take a leadership role in the world
and help lead the world towards the light
fade away from the darkness.
Yeah.
And
with that thought,
let's move away from the,
this darkness right now let's
talk about something else.
Not to forget about this,
but
we do have to recognize that we got to
live our lives and people got to live
their lives. And again, don't
deny that this stuff is out there.
Don't forget that this stuff is out
there. Relish your situation. If you're,
if you have a MP,
three player of some kind and you're
listening to this podcast, be thankful.
Be Thankful that you're in that situation
and look down below you into the darkness.
And if you get the chance,
put out your hand and see if
there's someone down there,
okay.
That you can help pull up.
So, uh, out of that heaviness
and out of that darkness,
let's head into a little
bit of light now with, uh,
the community questions and questions
from the troopers out there.
I've got questions for us and
okay.
You know, before we talk about the, uh,
before we go to questions
from the inner webs,
what can we do from the interwebs
supporting the OP podcast style?
Yeah,
well it depends on your mission,
but in the event of you wanting to
support this podcast in any capacity,
um, well it's a bunch of things you
can do. You can uh, do your Amazon,
Amazon shopping.
Like if you want to get that book,
you want to buy this book right here,
which you should cause shitty season.
Cause it's an eye opener. I
don't know though. I don't know.
It might not be for everybody. I'm
telling you. If you're a human,
you should know about what the world is
like. I did get machete season. Yeah,
right there. If you want to get
that, for example, through Amazon,
just click through the link that is
on Jocko podcast.com or Jocko podcast.
[inaudible] dot com or Jocko store.
And by the way,
if you want to buy anything from
Amazon and you click through that link,
little some goes to the
podcast, right? Yeah.
So you're kind of passively
supporting. Um, also, you know what,
you know what I didn't realize
earlier today we have shirts.
Yeah.
Jocko podcast shirts there.
You know there are a couple of designs.
I've never mentioned it.
I posted a picture on Twitter before,
like a couple of pictures on Twitter.
That's it. I'm never mentioned it.
So that's another way to support
the podcast. Yeah, get yourself,
get yourself a shirt.
But there's a,
if you just look at the shirts there
at Jocko, store.com, look at them.
If you like it, if you like one of them
or, or both the designs or whatever,
get a shirt, you don't like
them, don't get the shyness.
That's simple enough. Yup.
There it is.
And then of course on it,
he's a
supporter of this podcast,
o n n I t.com/jocko and get 10% off
anything on it is where we alpha brain
to fuel this podcast. And we're
Jacobi's amongst the buildings. Yeah.
A bunch of other stuff.
Cool stuff and quality legitimate stuff.
I think that's a big deal because a
lot of times like you can take protein
supplements or something
like that and it won't work,
but you won't really even know. You
want to get to clean stuff. Yeah.
You want to get the good stuff. And
this, and I've mentioned this before,
you can get caught up on that website
reading all the interesting stuff,
like how they get this and how they get
these ingredients, all that stuff. Um,
which actually isn't a bad thing
because you know now, but, um,
nonetheless it's all
right there. You can, uh,
you can read about all the supplements
that you're thinking about getting.
I recommend shroom tech sport as always.
If you're going to do hard stuff that's
like extended in a hard like Jujitsu or
you know,
across it situation or that kind of stuff.
She always called a crossfit
situation yet as if it's on,
that's going to occur like crying.
I appreciate that.
O n n I t.com/jocko 10% off free
shipping except for the exercise,
the heavy exercise stuff. Oh
yeah, there it is. Awesome.
It's got some questions going.
Okay. First Question Jocko,
can you tell us your views on Brazilian
Jujitsu competing mindset and training
leading into a competition?
Well, competing is great.
Competing makes you better.
Competing points out your weaknesses.
Competing lets you roll against people
that you've never trained with before
that are going to go 1000% against
you and remove matters in competition.
Yes, they bring it. Uh,
I competed a ton back in the early days.
Um,
you know, you know, really, I'll just
talk about dean because Dean and I were,
were teammates back then and still are,
but we competed all the time and we
competed in the old school tournaments.
The uh, the grappling games,
they used to have those, the,
the,
the Pan American submission grappling.
It was sorta like some offshoot or
another competing sort of Pan Am's type
situation. Uh, my, my, there was the,
the Jo Marie era tournaments back
in the day. Those were pretty cool.
And uh,
the Copa Pacifica,
I think I did a few of
those back in the day,
but by my favorite was doing the neutral
grounds tournament's cause those were
like held up in La up in the
hood somewhere and we'd roll in,
it'd be kind of underground and those
were really cool competition. So,
but competed a ton back
in the day. Um, once,
honestly once September 11th happened,
that was now my focus
more than anything else.
And I needed to be ready
and need to be ready.
I couldn't be having a blown out knee. I
couldn't be having a hurt shoulder. So,
and furthermore, I had like less
time to focus and have real, like,
let's call it a training camp to be ready
to compete at a high level. And I mean,
I was at a high, you know, I mean, I was,
I was, you know, a brown belt
or black belt at the time.
And so it wasn't like you could just show
up the weekend warrior and jump in the
jump on the mat with a, you know, some,
some other black belt and it
was going to go easy for you.
It wasn't gonna Happen.
So I didn't, you know,
the bottom line is I needed to be 100%
for the job. Uh, but competing is awesome.
It's intense.
No matter what you do in training,
you cannot get a person as fired up as
they are going to be in competition.
It's not gonna happen.
So it's really good to,
to compete.
So you find out what your weaknesses,
you find out what it feels like when
someone's going psycho on you because
they're going to be going psycho.
And to prepare for them, you know,
you gotta you got to, my favorite
thing to do prepares, you know,
you get guys where they're going.
Got Fresh people coming on. Yeah.
Because everybody can be destroyed when
fatigue rolls in and starts getting,
playing a role in the situation.
It's been, it's good, it's bad.
So when you bring in a fresh person,
you know, after every two minutes,
three minutes, four minutes, one minute,
six minutes. But one person is, is,
is fighting the whole time and other
people are getting arrested and coming in.
That's very challenging.
It makes you rely on your technique.
It pushes you beyond your normal limits
and it's an awesome way to do it.
So that being said,
you also can't just do that all the
time because you have to train your
explosiveness as well and you
need to be ready to do, you know,
if you're doing a seven minute fight,
you need to be able to go
hard for seven minutes.
And not save everything
for a 38 minute fight,
which is what you sometimes
end up doing in the gym.
I do that all the time in
the gym. I'm doing yo six
rounds, seven rounds, you know,
nine rounds, whatever the case may be.
And you're also doing just one round,
but it's one round that's 23 minutes
long. Yeah, that happens too.
So I like to do a little bit of
all those things and but yeah,
compete,
get yourself better and it'll,
it'll definitely make you
a better Jujitsu player,
which will make you a better person.
And you see that pressure,
you don't want another tactic which is,
which is kind of good.
And Jeff will do this sometimes he'll
do like a three minute round. Yeah.
So it's strange because when you know
there's only three minutes that you kind
of get that illusion that I'm just going
to go all out and we'll see how many,
if I can get this guy,
I only have three minutes to get them.
And so you're to heart until your sense
of urgency is more than if you have an
eight minute route for your prep.
But here's the, here's the little,
and I dunno if Jeff did
this on purpose but purpose,
it's kind of this little trick where
you're going hard but he only gives us 30
seconds in between.
So it's,
it doesn't matter if it's the three main
area and you're going like six rounds.
Yeah.
So you're like,
and so that will test your conditioning
but it'll test like your quickness and
not quickness like quick,
but your urgency, you know,
you're not going to be just chilling
in some guys guard or you know,
cause cause it's, you can fossil to
chill in the guard. You can, yeah.
In fact that's actually a good
strategy in some cases. You know,
when you got every cover or
something like this. Anyway,
that's interesting one
that I to realize when
Jeff put it on us one
day. Love. Yes. Okay,
next question. Yeah, let's do it. Okay.
I hurt myself significantly throwing a
roundhouse kick recently abdominal hernia
at the site of an old appendix surgery.
I trained MMA five days a week,
sometimes more and multiple times a day
for two years until last week when he
got that injury.
But now I can hardly sit in a chair
without pain in surgery is two months out.
And who knows how long recovery recovery
will be. Um, before I can train again,
what I'm asking is what should we as
martial artists in men do in times of
forced hiatus an injury?
What do we do when there's a quiet,
but we miss the storm?
Well,
one thing with injuries,
injuries are going to come and you cut.
Would you get saw dust, you train,
you're going to get injured.
That's what's going to happen. I
mean, it's just a, that's just,
this is the law is the law of the land.
The number one thing to remember is,
and this is something that's really hard,
when you're super active and you're super
fired up and you're training all the
time, when you get injured
and you get sidelined,
you feel like it's never gonna go away.
It feels like it's not healing.
And you're just like, oh man,
this is, I'm doomed. So the,
the injury is going to wick go away.
Now obviously for some guys, for some,
for some actual soldiers or warriors
that had been wounded in a permanent way,
that's, that's different. And those guys,
what they do is they learn to adapt.
You know, they learn how are
they going to get through this?
How are they gonna adapt their life?
How are they going to roll with one leg?
How are they going to do pull ups
with one hand? Uh, Jeffrey Owl,
you know Jeffrey out. Yup.
We're doing a burpee pull ups.
The other day I was putting
the MMA classes through it.
If you don't know Jeffrey l awesome guy,
awesome fighter, awesome Jujitsu player.
He's born without one hand.
I had the guys doing a burpee pull
ups and black belt by the way. Yeah.
Black belts.
And he had uh,
he has like a little hook he can put
on there to do pull ups and I guess the
thing was fallen off.
And so he just threw that thing to the
ground and he was just hooking his,
his forearm over and then the other hand
was grabbing. He's doing pull ups. Yeah.
I mean if,
if Jeffrey owl can just jump
do, we did, I don't know,
six rounds worth of burpee pull ups or
five rounds worth of burpee pull ups. He,
and he crushed it.
No one has any excuse.
So guys that they get some kind of a
permanent injury, they get wounded.
W something like that happens.
Okay. You got to adapt to it.
You've got to figure out what you
can do. But the injuries, the,
the basic injuries, the
daily injuries, the,
the temporary injuries that
is normal from training
that that's you're going to get them.
And so of course,
oh, you got an injury. Good. Right.
It's a little injury. Be Thankful.
It's not something worse.
You know, I, I've, I've had,
you know, a blown out ankle.
I've had a torn MCL and you know,
what do you do?
What do you say when you tear your ACL or
your MCL, you say, okay, awesome. Yeah,
I did. It's not my ACL, it's
not my meniscus. You know,
the MCL will he itself,
what do you say? If it's your,
if it is your ACL. Okay, great.
That's one that can be
repaired with surgery.
So none of these problems are permanent,
right?
So be thankful you don't
have a permanent injury.
Okay.
And even though it seems like it's going
to take forever, like homeboy here,
who's got two months before he even gets
surgery and then how long is it going
to take? It seems like it's going to
take forever. I had neck surgery, right?
That was a blip on the radar,
if you remember how long it took.
And it was a long time. I mean,
it took months to heal from that.
I don't remember that when I do,
during that time I did other exercises.
I figured it out. This stuff.
I watched youtube videos,
I figured out all the moves,
you know? That's what I did.
So I guess youtube wasn't even around.
I was watching DVDs,
GGT, DVDs, VHS tapes.
So what do you do? Number one,
stay active. Right? You know,
move. Do, if you,
if you can't move your body all
work your forearms. Strength,
right? Squeeze a tennis ball. One
of my buddies blew out his knee.
What is it? The triple threat.
He did ACL, PCL, meniscus, boom.
He'll hook right,
didn't tap,
got to adapt to the heel hook people got
attached to it, got caught on a hill.
It didn't tap blue is blue.
It all apart. He was in a,
he had to get them all
reconstructed. So he, we had a dummy.
Remember the big dummy we have at the gym?
We had a big one,
it was 120 pounds and he
would lay on the ground.
His knee is in a four, has legs and a
fourth street brace won't bend at all.
He would lay on the ground and in lay
next to this dummy and he just pull it
from one side of himself, put it on the
ground, on the other side of itself,
pull it back to the other side, back to
the other side, back to the other side.
So he's getting this motion of
sort of turning on the ground,
this massive core strength. And
when we, when he finally recovered,
it was powerful. You know what, he would
turn underneath. You said you got some,
got some strength there. So you've got
to figure out what you can do. You know,
if you can't roll,
yeah,
box.
If you can't box lift,
if you can't lift,
stretch and get that flexibility working
in some area that you're not flexible,
what? Whatever you're going to
do. Stay engaged. Stay active.
Because I think I'm definitely
a believer in the active rest.
You know what I mean? When you
just go, okay, I'm injured,
so I'm just gonna sit on the couch
and watch TV. No wrong answer.
Runaway from that TV,
you got to keep moving because that
keeps your blood flowing and it keeps
getting, it gets more
blood, more circulation,
more healing gives to this area
that's injured. So do that.
And if you're still, you're still gonna
have more time in your day, right?
So what are you going to do?
I'll tell you what you're gonna do.
Okay?
Get a guitar, right? Learn to play
guitar. Write a book, build a website,
take pictures, learn a
language, read more books.
Expand your brain,
right?
Expand your mind when your
body needs a little recovery.
When your body's injured, make
yourself smarter, make yourself better,
free your mind.
And so the bottom line,
the question was,
what does a man do when there's quiet?
And I'll tell you what a man does when
there's quiet, he takes advantage of it.
So take advantage of it.
Get Smarter, get better.
You know the ways and when the body comes
back you'll, you will be better. Yeah.
That's a good way to put it. Like
take advantage of it. Like actively.
Cause a lot of times like
where the problem comes about.
I know this because when I told I told
my bicep. That's right. I wasn't there.
I was watching the out. Yeah. Well
yeah. Thank you. Yeah, I was fine.
I have a picture of you. Yeah. That was
laying on the ground. That was messed up.
I think you sent me a smarmy
techs or something like that. No,
that was for something else. But the
same day though, nonetheless, what,
where the problem comes
when you miss the story,
you miss the action is
you're harping on it.
It's almost like you have this
hope like, oh, it'll be stolen.
Or maybe the doctor said nine months,
but maybe I could do it in four
kind of thing. You know, they just,
that mindset where you kind of in a
way got admit to yourself, okay, I'm,
I'm out right now.
I can't roll right now.
I can't train MMA two times a day,
five days a week. I cannot do that.
You got to admit that.
So where did you go?
Did you work on your video editing skills
during that time? Oh man, that was,
I think that was before,
or what'd you do? I forget.
I don't know, but I'll
tell you, do not take it.
Tell you what I didn't do is harp on it.
He moved on and you figured out what
else you can do. Yeah, exactly right.
In my back,
I was always into working out and stuff,
so I would do other stuff like legs and
stuff. Like your left arm. Hello? Yeah.
Yeah. Actually my left arm is still
bigger a little bit. Nonetheless.
I think that that's,
that's a good little jumpstart is don't
harp on it and you got to admit to
yourself that you're, you're out.
You're injured right now. So,
and then how you said take
advantage of it. Dang, that's good.
I wish I would've known that.
Actively take advantage because
there's so much advantage to be taken.
There's all kinds of
time you have. Yeah, man.
I think about all the time that I
spend in the gym and all the maths.
I mean that's a budge big chuck of time.
Now like with,
with reading for example,
it got back into reading and um,
look, I look at it this way where as
far as books go, books that exist,
any information in the whole, whether
you're interested in it, not interested,
whether you can understand it or not,
all the information of the
world is accessible right now,
especially more than anytime ever.
All different angles,
different aspects of everything is just
out there and you have more time now.
Take advantage of that actively.
Actively. All. Alright, next question.
My question is this,
as a military man,
what do you do if you can not reconcile
the orders that you're asked to do?
I know that in your book you talk about
believe the mission and how you must ask
questions until you believe what happens
if after all the questions and all the
expectation as explanations
that you don't agree or believe.
What if the policies,
the politics asks of you something
you're not congruent with.
How do you as a military men
respond to you're incongruent see
with the mission.
So this is a great question and, and, and
you know what's kind of ties in with
what we just read with the book review of
Machete sees and how
people were just doing it.
Some of them didn't believe in what
they're doing. They did it anyways.
Wrong answer. Um, Danny resulted in
the death of the one guy, you know,
you talk about her, the, that's
in the book, but you know,
so first of all, as you, as you
stated in the question itself,
if you don't agree with some
mission that you've been given,
then you have to ask the question
why in the book extreme ownership,
we talk about that.
The primary example is we talk about
is working with Iraqi soldiers.
And how that's very challenging and
very difficult and very dangerous.
And the story that we tell in the book
is that I, I said to myself, okay,
why are they having us work with,
he's Iraqi soldiers,
my guys are going to be at
risk, et Cetera, et cetera.
And eventually I realized why we needed
to do this was because if we didn't get
the Iraqi soldiers to a point where
they could handle the security in Iraq,
then who's going to do it? And the
answer was us. So I understood why.
Now I actually don't even have to
ask anybody why I figured that out.
I asked myself why and so I was able
to come to it, come to that conclusion.
But when you are a part of something,
okay
with whether it's in business,
awards in war, the goal,
the ultimate goal,
it has to be aligned and in it.
So for example,
we're in Iraq, we're supposed
to use Iraqi soldiers. Okay.
Do you think that the generals wanted
our med to be killed because of the,
the higher risk? No, they wanted to win
the war. They want to keep our guys safe.
So that's what I want it to.
We want to win the war.
We want to keep our guys
safe so that's aligned.
So anything that they're telling me to do,
it must be at some point in the distance
aligned with the same goal that I have.
And it's the same thing with a business.
Do you think a boss of a business doesn't
want to be profitable or doesn't want
to be ethical?
No.
Somewhere in the future they want to be
profitable and they want to be ethical
and somewhere your mission
is going to align with that.
If you don't,
if those don't align at some point,
then you've got a real serious
issue on your hands. Right?
Because maybe you're being told to do
something that you just don't believe in
at you at first. You know, like I said,
you've got to ask those questions all
the way up and if you do ask those
questions all the way up
and you still find, okay,
I don't believe in this mission.
Now you got a way out.
The consequences. Because,
for instance,
if there is an order that comes and for
whatever reason you don't believe in it,
and you've asked the questions and you
still don't believe that it's the right
thing to do. But what if it's something
that's like pretty inconsequential, right?
Something that's no big
deal and you say no to it.
Like I'm not going to do this. You
decide to make your stand, okay,
well now you are your,
first of all,
you're not supporting the
chain of command anymore.
And if you're not supporting
your chain of command anymore,
how can you support the
guys that work for you?
Hmm.
Because now,
now you might get removed and if you
get removed from the situation now,
who's going to go execute it?
Who's going to go do this thing
that you thought was wrong?
Now you're going to give it to somebody
that might execute it in a harsher way,
in a worse way or, or you lose control
of it. You've lost your influence,
your use of some of
your political capital.
You've impaired your reputation by saying,
no,
I'm not gonna do that because I don't
believe in it. Well, what was it?
And by saying, no, what
did you accomplish?
Because now you have no control
over in, the more you're, you're,
you can't change it, you can't affect
it any more. So let me ask you this.
This is an example. This will make
it very clear what I'm trying to say,
cause I don't think I'm being very clear
right now. If you're playing a game,
right?
You're playing a football
game or a basketball game
and the ref makes a bad call.
Okay? So you say ref made a bad
call. I don't agree with this call.
I quit.
I'm walking off the court
now.
Does that make sense? I mean,
how bad of a call was it?
How did it affect the game? And, and
furthermore, once you walk off the court,
what good are you? Can you,
can you do better? Can use,
try and bring back the score.
Can you try and show the ref that yes,
you are playing fair. Look, I'm
a good guy and keeping my head.
I'm keeping my cool.
Now you've thrown that all away.
You've thrown that all the way.
And so what good is that?
It's the same thing and not to the ref,
cause that's sort of outside your chain
of command. But what if your own coach,
what if your coach pulls you out of a
game or a coach calls a play to you for
you to run a play that you didn't
believe in? So you're going to say,
you know what? I don't believe in
that play. I'm walking off the field.
That's an exact correlation to this idea,
right?
This military order comes
down that I don't believe in.
Oh, I don't believe in it.
So now I'm going to walk away.
Right?
So
that is is problematic because you've,
you've given up, you've surrendered
your right to affect the situation.
Yeah.
And that's,
that's not good.
And in the military there's
all kinds of little, you know,
policy nuances that we might not
believe in 100%, little things.
There might be little things that you
go, you know what? I don't, I don't see,
I don't think that's
the best way to do it.
Or I think there's a better way to do it.
But if you walk away from it now,
you can no longer affect it and
that is bad. So generally speaking,
for most of these things you,
I dealt,
dealt with in the military all the time,
dealt with it all the time.
And you know what?
Generally speaking,
you stay in the game so that you can
still have an effect and can still have
influence.
Now that being said,
there can be orders that
are on lawful or unethical.
That can't happen, right? If
you are in a bad situation,
you're working for a bad commander,
you're working for someone that's
unethical or whatever the case may be.
It may be their orders are plans that
are tactically on the sound to the point
that you're afraid
people are going to die.
And, and in those situations, you know,
as we were rolling back to Napoleon's
maximum, again, if you knew,
execute something that you knew was wrong,
you're comparable.
So that is a time when you stand up and
say, you know what? I'm not doing this.
You want to send me to Leavenworth? Do
you want to demote me, demote me, do it.
But I did not believe in this.
And here's why.
So that is a time where
you may have to say,
after you weigh out the situation, how
bad is it? Something that's unethical,
unconstitutional,
and you think you're going to have a
bigger impact by protesting it by possibly
jeopardizing your career or
possibly going to go on 11 worth.
If you're in the military,
getting court martialed,
all those things could happen if you
think that it's so important and that you
will have a better effect on it by
making this protest because that's what
you're doing.
You're now making a protest then okay,
maybe that makes sense.
So you've got like the Mei Lai
massacre in Vietnam were horrible.
Situation happens. And if you were
a soldier that was there and said,
you know what,
I'm not doing this stop.
And maybe maybe you do rest and court
martialed maybe risk getting killed.
But that's a situation where maybe you
do it or maybe it's some mistreatment of
civilians or something. But again,
even with mistreatment of civilians,
the u s military is not going to
order the mistreatment of civilians.
It's not going to happen,
right? So if it is happening,
it's coming from a rogue commander
that's you're going to be able to destroy
when you bring this situation to the,
to the authorities or to
the higher chain of command.
So again,
you know,
if getting wrapped up in
some small nuanced thing,
he mentions the Poli,
the political,
like if you're not
politically congruent with,
I don't know if you meant
that split. Yeah. And again,
when you're in the military,
you're, you're not there to, um,
worry about the politics of it. You know,
you're there to carry out the politics.
You're there to carry out the
policy. Now if there's a Po, again,
if the policy is agregious, right, right.
If it's a green adjusts and you
think you would do better to,
to make a protest and end
up in jail and you know,
be on CNN and Fox News and saying,
Hey,
this is why I'm in jail because I
didn't agree with what we're doing.
If it's something that the rest of the
nation is going to look at and say, yeah,
this guy was right.
Right, of course. Yeah.
But if you're doing it
because it's something that
is in comparison to that is
something relatively small.
Okay,
then you're probably, you're probably
doing worse to help the situation.
You're probably doing
less good by walking away,
getting off the field and letting,
letting the,
the situation transpire without
your presence. I want to be there.
Yeah. You know, I want to be there. If I,
if my guys were getting tasked with a
mission that I thought was a little bit
sketchy, I want to be there. Yeah.
I want to be there. Not, hey,
I protest, so I'm not going to
go [inaudible] not a good call.
So, um, yeah, and, and again,
I'm not saying that you don't stand by
your principles, but what I'm saying is,
especially if this guy
that's in the military,
your principles should be for the
most part in line, this is America.
And if you're, if you're, if you're
being told to do something that's,
that's UNAMERICAN, then yeah.
Stand by your principles. But most,
if it's something that's small and it's
something that you just might not agree
with, 100%, it doesn't mean
you're an unprincipled person.
It means that you are winning,
losing the battle,
but you're going to win the war. Yeah.
Yeah. I liked that way. Weigh it out.
You know, everything's not
black and white. That bothers
me. I'm jumping on the,
you know,
on that side of things.
Yeah.
Next question,
Jocko and echo.
What supplements do you guys take
besides Krill oil and Alpha brain
in d?
Take the Alpha brain instant or capsules.
I take Alpha brain instant. It's tasty
treat. It's got a little statistic,
which it's got a little sweetness to
it, uh, cause it's got Stevia in it,
so it tastes good.
If you,
if you have a little bit of a sweet tooth
and wants something sweet and you've
been eating like steak for
the past seven days, mmm.
Tastes good. I also take glucosomine
as I've mentioned before. Uh,
I do get it from on it. It's a product
called strong bone. That's what I,
that's what I take. And I'll tell you, I,
I the getting ready for the
podcast, right. Doing prep work,
like three days in a row,
I was deep in prep work
and I was pounding some,
some Alpha brain and
each, each dance. Yeah.
I was like drinking the full Alpha
brains and maybe like two of them.
And,
and I,
I had directed the two days in a row
and when I went into train and I trained
with Dean deans getting ready
for something right now,
and I was rolling really
good with Dean each day.
I was, you know, I was doing
well. He has, I was like, dude,
it was doing well and dean was,
Dean was not a happy camper.
And then the third day was like,
I was pretty much done with wrapped up
the prep and I didn't have any Alpha and
I had a rough day and I, I said to
myself, maybe there's a little slot there.
Causation, I don't know,
maybe, but, uh, yeah.
And I suppose you want to throw out
some shroom tech. Yeah. Shroom tech. Um,
of course, like I've always said,
um, again, even before this I was,
I took from tech. That was good. That's
a good one. Oh, the preworkout sometimes,
you know, we'll actually
all the time, if you,
if you really want to feel like
working out, you know, like, like, Hey,
I feel like working out right now.
You'll always feel like that.
You feel like that takes some
pre workout with the Alpha brain.
Instant mix them together.
Boom, Gatorade, boom. Yeah. Um,
as far as the Alpha brain
instant versus the capsules, and
my brother has verified this, I'd
never taken, I've taken the capsules,
but not before I go to sleep.
I hear that if you take the
capsules before you go to sleep,
cause I don't think there's like any
kind of caffeine or nothing in Alphago.
There's not so take it
before you go to sleep,
you get 'em lucid dreams,
lucid dreams. I've heard that.
I've heard that from everybody.
Everybody who takes Alpha brain,
they say that it affects the dream.
I don't want my dreams to be any
more real than they are actually.
But do you know that
you're dreaming when you,
when you saw three dream
situation? Sometimes. Yeah.
Apparently like this a little bit.
A lot of times my dreams are just blank,
but I wake up and you know, complete full
athletic, sweat drenched bed. That's,
that's how I wake up.
It's not fun. Yeah. Um,
but in regards to like protein powder
or nothing like this, uh, steak.
Yes. I said it before and I'll say it
again. Yeah. I think that's a big deal.
Like a lot of people, you know, people,
some people were really into supplements
like Toby. Yeah. The new, this,
the new protein powder because it comes
with this delivery system and all this
stuff. Um, dual action protein. Yeah. You
know, all this other stuff. And it does,
um, like if you eat food that, yeah,
just normal food that has a good
delivery system that is to tell you that
actually,
especially when it's in the form of a
Ribeye steaks and great delivery system
right there. Yeah. I would
imagine so. But yeah, that's it.
Not that heavy into the supplements.
Um, maybe a multivitamin
from time to time. Okay.
I don't really take a multivitamin. Yeah.
Yeah, I did for awhile. I don't anymore.
Yeah. Um, Krill oil. Alpha
brain. Yeah, it's it.
Next question.
I'm a Kentucky Trooper and I'm
an instructor at our academy,
the police academy. We lost three guys
last year. Could you discuss how it,
how to deal with training these guys
as hard as you can and they still lose
their lives while working.
So it's the dealing with people
and letting them know that um,
hm
that this goes down.
Know How do you do with that?
Well, first of all, um,
I eat a lot of feedback from police
officers out there in the world and if I
would say one thing to them to lead
this office, thank you for what you do.
You guys have a dangerous job.
It's intense,
it's thankless most of the time
and you're dealing with the,
with the dregs of society all day long.
And then you have to balance that
with dealing with normal civilians and
citizens. So, uh,
thank you for what you guys do.
And also I'll throw on top of that.
Firefighters, you know,
paramedics. Thank you guys.
For what you do. And
again, thankless job, um,
difficult job,
dangerous job where people,
you're helping people that don't want
to help themselves in many cases.
So thanks for everybody.
Thanks for all those,
those first responders for
what you guys do. Yeah. Um,
now as far as training guys hard and
then you still get guys that get killed
blessing. But let me ask you
this. What is the alternative?
Right? Well, what are you going to
do? Not Train hard. Um, you know,
I had the first deals that were killed
in Iraq were killed under my command.
There were my guys, mark, Mark Lee,
Mikey Mon store and Ryan Job.
And we trained as hard as possible
and we still took those casualties.
I'm telling you,
we trained as hard as possible and if it
wasn't for lack of training or lack of
planning or lack of skill,
okay.
It's the nature of combat
eats the risk of conducting
operations in a hostile environment.
And I'll tell you what,
when I got back to America and I took
over the training for the west coast seal
teams,
that fact,
that fact of losing my guys in combat,
it made me fanatical about trading.
And I was already fanatical about
training, but it multiplied it infinitely.
Okay.
Because now it became my
mission to prepare these guys,
the apps to the absolute best of my
ability and get them ready for combat.
In part of that preparation was making
them understand what was at risk.
And I think that's something
that you should do here.
You know,
you don't know what's going to happen
when you go into the field and you don't
know when it's gonna happen.
So everything you do should be to prepare
yourself mentally and physically for
the moment of truth.
Whether that happens at a traffic stop
or while you're serving a warrant and why
you're stopping a bank robbery,
you don't know when it is going to happen.
And so you got to tell these guys,
tell them the truth of the danger
and let it sink in and hound on it.
And I, I, I tell this story from
time and I was telling you a story.
It's a statement and it's
because I remember this feeling.
Then it was when I got back
from Ramadi and we were doing,
we'd be doing urban training and I would
see a guy like standing in the street
standing in the middle of the street,
which is, which is not a good move, right?
That's where bullets fly down.
You're going to get shot if you're in
the Middle Street and it happen all the
time to guys and Ramadi and I would
see a guy that will be standing in the
street and I would literally feel sick.
It was only for about maybe six
to nine months after I got back.
When I'd gone to the training side,
I would feel sick to my stomach.
I would just feel this horrible feeling
because it was like I was waiting for
something to be,
I was waiting for him to get shot
and he felt horrible and I wore,
my goal was to transfer that
feeling into their heads.
I wanted them to feel sick.
I wanted them to feel embarrassed and
feel guilty and feel angry and feel
disappointed that they were doing
something wrong because I wanted them to
change their behavior,
which would keep them alive.
So I would say in this
case, whew, you've got,
you're putting people through training,
valuable training,
and of course there's still going
to go out and do a dangerous job,
but you don't back off the training,
you train harder and you
use these guys again.
God bless him.
You use these guys that were
killed in action as an example of,
hey guys, this is why we're training
hard. This is why we're going to push.
This is why I want you to take
personal responsibility for and for
your training and for your
skill set so that you're ready.
Yeah.
You train how you fight and
you fight how you train.
So take advantage of that and be ready.
Yeah. And a lot of times that, that
pain of, um, you know, any kind of fail,
in this case, it's an extreme
case. Losing your guys. You know,
you guys are going through these
extreme cases, um, and that, you know,
so there's a spectrum of, you know, of
cases, but any kind of failure or, or,
or mishap that causes any kind of pain.
Okay.
You can, and it's not easy. It's not easy,
but you can use that pain to facilitate
your passion in a corrective way.
You know, I was like,
how you say train harder.
You can take that pain
and literally focus on
good ways of training, training, hard,
being attached to the results of training
you're in or the process of training.
Yeah. You know, and it, and it'll, you
get essentially you can use that pain,
you know? Absolutely. You,
you get a guy that's an MMA fighter
that loses to a submission hold, right.
You take that and you say, okay, but
you've got to work though Jujitsu.
You take a guy that's gets his legs
kicked out from underneath him. Okay,
you got to work.
You're more tired.
So you take those painful
training experiences and
you put them, like you said,
you put them to work. Absolutely.
Yeah. In the, in a lot of times,
a lot of times that'll come naturally
a lot of times, but it doesn't always.
So in those cases, you can just, just
actively and consciously take that pain,
you know, and, and redirect it. You
can do it. You can do that fully,
even if it doesn't come
natural and it helps.
Yeah.
Okay. Jacqueline, any advice? Um, you
have to continue to work out at 4:30 AM
but with two newborn twins at home because
the struggle to stay awake and real.
Awesome question. And,
well, I have four kids.
The first three of them were
born in pretty rapid succession,
not quite twins obviously,
but you know,
we had at one point we had
three kids under three. So yeah,
we're getting after it.
And, uh, now part of that,
I got to, in full disclosure,
I, you know, I was, uh,
deployed a fair amount,
but
when you got those young kids, here's
what you gotta do, you gotta get it done.
You got to get it done.
And this idea that you're going to
get it done on some pattern or some
structured time schedule. It's
gonna. It's gonna fall apart. Yeah,
and you got to both sleep and working
out and every other thing that you're
trying to get done in your life,
you have to make it happen when
you can make it happen, right.
You know you have to make it happen.
When can make it happen,
there's going to be no ideal time.
You might be working out at
three o'clock in the morning.
You might be working out
at seven o'clock at night.
You might be working out at midnight.
You might be trying to sleep at noon.
You don't know what's going to happen.
I would definitely say when
you got the young kids,
get some kind of a home gym set up.
At least get a pullup bar.
At least get yourself a pullup bar.
Because if you have a pull up bar,
you can do everything. You can do
pull ups. Then you can do push ups.
You can do squats, you can do sprints.
You can, you can make stuff work.
If you at least have a pullup bar and
then you just got to squeeze it in there.
You know, it's a half an hour there. It's
20 minutes here, it's 15 minutes there.
It's a power nap in the afternoon.
It's some squats while you're
sitting there holding a baby,
trying to get the baby to fall asleep.
That's what it is.
It's the stroller to the
park with a chalk bag.
So when you get there,
you can do some pull ups on the swing set.
That's what it becomes because life is
going to have a vote in these situations
and your kids and your family
are more important than you are.
And that's something that is a tough
reality for the young dads to face.
All of a sudden you are not the most
important thing in the world at all.
They are more important than you are.
That being said, which I know I'm
supposed to, uh, pay some kind of a fine.
When I say that being said,
somebody on Twitter hassled me about it.
That being said,
so your kids are more important than you.
Your family's more important to
you. That being said, guess what?
The number one thing you need
to do for them, stay healthy.
You got to stay healthy.
You can't get all outta shape and turn
into a bum just because you got kids.
They're looking to you to be able
to provide for them for a long time.
They're also looking at you as an example.
That's a big one.
So you gotta be the right kind of example,
and physical fitness is
part of that example.
So they should see that from day one.
They should know big daddy's doing some
squats while he's holding me [inaudible].
Now I'm going to double
down. That being said,
this is not a time of your life when you
have newborn twins that you're going to
be in the optimal condition. You're not
going to be at your peak performance.
That's okay, right? That's okay. Hey man,
you got things going on at you're a dad.
You know you're not new.
Dad would [inaudible] you're not going
to be setting any of your prs on your,
on your dead lift. Right? It's
not going to happen. So, but,
but that's not a reason
that you fall apart at all.
You got to hold the
line as much as you can.
You've got to balance this situation.
Now you got a in dig in,
you gotta be creative with your workout,
with your rest, with your sleep.
When the opportunity presents itself,
whichever one of those is the priority,
you've got to go and get it on
and you know,
it'll happen.
It's not just when you have newborn kids,
it'll happen with your job.
You'll,
you'll get some pressure situation at
work and all of a sudden you're going to,
you got to squeeze it in. You know, I had,
I bought houses over time and I would
always buy these houses that were
unlivable, right. Just on livable,
just brand sack disasters
because they were cheaper.
And then I would go in and do these
like speed remodels alone by yourself,
by myself. But you know,
for instance, I did a,
I gutted a kitchen in one of my houses,
gutted the kitchen and redid the
whole kitchen, plumbing, electrical,
new counters, the whole
thing. And I got it.
I didn't get the countertops in
because that was like, you know,
especially guys come in and do that.
But 72 hours,
72 hours,
nonstop work.
When I moved into another house I had,
we pulled up the carpet.
I thought there was these nice
hardwood floors under the carpet,
pulled up water damage.
A third of the,
a little bit more than a third of the
phone was half the floor is water damage.
So I had to yank those boards out and
then saying this whole thing and it was a
nightmare.
It took me 72 hours of no sleep.
I would sleep for 20
minutes waiting for the,
the next layer of varnish to dry
sitting there in the fumes. Right.
But that's what you gotta do
sometimes you got to be, like I said,
a big project at work,
something that's coming. Uh,
and you got to figure out how to,
what you can fit in,
when you can fit it in and
realize that there's benefit.
There's benefit to that
20 minute little session.
You just did go do a hundred burpees,
right? Go swing a kettle bell,
just go swipe. I always talking about
the other day we, I got Kettlebell,
I got the, I got the, uh, the
Zombie Bells, right? I got
the Zombie Bells. You know,
I have a garage gym.
The Zombie Bells are in my house
because I'm walking around.
And sometimes you need to
snatch a kettle bell too, right?
Sometimes you go snatch a kettle bell.
So,
so you have that and that builds up
because now you're just boom, you hit out.
You know, you're not even breaking
into a sweat, just hitting seven,
seven each arm, you know, cannibal snatch.
Maybe it's just, you're just doing that.
Yeah. And so that's the kind of thing
maybe, you know, with the newborn dad,
you got to have that get to have that
Zombie Bow Sydney House and he just to hit
some snatches ready just to do some, some,
some sumo dead lift, high pulse. Right.
What's it going to be? Make it
happen. We'll get the pull up bar or,
or a set of rings. Get the rings.
Yeah. You know, something that you can,
rings are great cause then you can do
pull ups, you can do dips. They're very,
very versatile, very versatile. But
you're going to, the bottom line here is
your life is going to change.
It has changed.
So it doesn't mean, and
you're, you know what,
your life has changed and it just
got better. It just got better.
So what you need to do is you need to
adapt to the new situation and continue to
drive the excellence.
But the excellence isn't going
to be served up all at once.
The excellence is going to be served up
in little chunks throughout the day day
where you can grab it. Yeah. And that's
uh, that's the way it goes. Yeah.
Another tip in, um, I am a
twin. I don't have twins.
Yeah. If you don't know, uh, Echo
Charles is a twin. And by the way,
you've got some requests
for the echos story.
So maybe next podcast we can wear here.
Echoes Story.
Yeah. Um, yeah, sure.
I'll give you three minutes and 30 seconds
for it. Good story. I thought I need,
um, but no one, when I
had my daughter and I'm,
I'm pretty into working out,
so you know,
to not work out with kind of hard or
not have the time, but here's the thing,
I'm really into like the
luxurious situation resting
for a long time and getting
ready mentally ready,
like taking an hour and a half to get
ready for what I was used to that.
So that was a big,
a big change to not have that much rest
and not have to have that much time. So,
and now you're doing Jocko podcasts,
you get even less as less rest. Well,
she's three now, so it's different. Um,
but a thing that helps on
top of everything you said,
which is in my opinion,
absolutely correct, 100%, um,
to add to it is work with your wife
or husband if you're a girl, you know,
and your, and you guys have kind of
communicate with them, tell them that,
you know,
working out in staying in shape is,
is important to me or whatever or in a
good way to put it is getting unhealthy
at this time with our new kids is
means a lot, you know, if I do that,
like it means a lot to stay
healthy. Um, so you know,
if you communicate that will help as well
because you can work with each other.
You know, how like, you know,
when you have a new kids, um,
it's kind of like one guy can, you know,
capitalize on a rest time, you know,
and then you know,
the other guy will kind of stand,
watch with the kids and the other,
the other person can, can get rest.
So if you communicate,
that'll help your situation so much.
So I am guilty here of unintentional
communications because if I,
you know what, when, when, when my
wife and I, when our kids were young,
if I didn't work out,
and quite honestly if I didn't train
Jujitsu, I am guilty. I'm, yeah,
I was, I, I wouldn't
recognize, but it just would
really like frustrate me. Right. And
so eventually she said, you know what,
just get your stupid ass
outta here and go train. Yeah.
Because I'd rather just have you go, and
that's when, that's when I, you know, we,
I'd show up at the gym at
eight o'clock at night,
like Dean would be done teaching class
and I'd come in there and we trained for
38 minutes, you know, just go in
there, get it on and come home.
So, you know, try not to do
that where you're a jerk. Right.
But there's something, I mean I talk
about this all the time, that there is,
there is a mind body connection
that is undeniable. Yeah. For sure.
And if you don't find a place to get
that aggression out and get that the
endorphins flowing and get the,
the,
the good feeling that you
get from physical activity,
then you're going to turn you and turn a
little bit nasty. That's not good. Yeah.
And of course that,
that I bet you a lot of relationships
really suffer from that and people don't
recognize it. I think so do I think in my
experience from talking to people, okay,
so, okay, but so that
element, that element of,
of exercising and it being interrupted
by a new kids or something like that,
that'll vary from person to person.
Right.
So you being all nuts because
you can't train, you know,
the next guy might not be that nuts.
They might affect him maybe this much,
it would be this much,
you know,
it's different m and a that
goes along with what I said,
like communicating,
actively telling him
like, you know, doing what
you did but communicate.
And at the same time, if you're aware
of it, which it can be the hard part,
if you're aware that you're just
not as happy, just just know that.
So really kind of check yourself if you
feel yourself losing your temporary, I'm,
I'm, you know, I'm unhappy because
I'm sacrificing a few training days.
You're right. The red flag of
that's, that's a great point.
The red flag of,
Hey,
it sucks having kids. Yes.
You have the red flag.
The reason you're feeling that is because
it's this part of that reasons because
it's disrupting your physical activity.
So recognize that and then
do something about it. Yeah.
Communicate with your spouse,
you know, set up a plan.
Get a pull up bar, get a
kettle bell in the house. Yeah.
Do and make it happen. Yeah. And the,
I think that's a good point. Yeah.
It's not going to be as luxurious as you
know. You're not going to be optimum.
It's not a time. And a lot of them will
with me. That bothered me. You know, not,
it didn't, I didn't really
pay much of a price, you know,
as far as it bothering me
when something bothers me,
I don't like lose my temper typically,
but I did feel that I'd be like,
oh my gosh,
I don't have that much time or I don't
have the energy because they didn't get
enough sleep and it was kind of annoying.
But
at the same time I did adapt and
I got real good at um, you know,
like the exercise like Jim Gymnast can
do it like on a pommel horse or something
or I'd go on the ground,
I'd sit with my legs and feet out in
front and you can live, he'll sit. Yeah.
Yeah man, I got real good at
doing that. But nonetheless,
the doctor, the Jujitsu
thing, um, two things. Yeah.
Communicate,
understand when you're starting to get
a little irritated because he didn't,
didn't train, understand that
and then handle it accordingly.
That's a, on the flip side,
if you have to recognize,
okay this is a typical situation
where now you have kids,
yet you still want to go train Jujitsu,
but your wife is like how,
how can you reconcile going to
train with your buddies? You know,
cause a lot of times the girlfriend or
the wife will think that that's just some,
some fun and games and you know,
in their mind they think it's another
relationship you basically have going on
but they don't understand the
important of Gel. The bottom,
the Jujitsu potentially.
Yes. And it's the spectrum.
So it's important to to,
like I said,
communicate and let them, let them
know that it's not that, you know,
and they don't always get it.
I understand that.
But if you just can communicate and
effectively get the message that it is an
important thing in life,
hey listen Darlin what's important to you?
What's it you know, cause you never
know what it is. Whether it's running,
whether it's their biking
or whether it's there,
anything date night with their
girls or whatever the case may be.
That's what you've got. This is what
I've got. I've got these two things.
You have got to work out. I got
to train some Jujitsu. Yeah.
You know that's when I got to do.
But beef be fair though.
Like if you're going seven days a week
before the kids and you still want to go
seven days a week, three hours
a day, understand that. Okay,
you got kids not going to
bring it down to like six.
I was really bad.
Yeah I can see that.
But it's in a way it's not fair,
you know,
like not only to your wife but to
the fact that you have kids now.
You know there's only so
much Jocko Kingo around.
Yeah I don't,
I'm questioning whether I should
tell this but I'm going to.
So there was times where
I would come home from,
work in the seal teams work
until seven o'clock at night,
come home from work,
walk through the door,
drop my work bag and pick up my gym bag.
My wife's there with three young
kids and she would be looking at me
with the expression of
are you freaking serious?
Cause you know, I'm only home
for, let's call it four days,
then I'm going on another trip
and I'm home for three days.
So those four days she's thinking, cool,
he's home for four days, family time.
I'm thinking cool home for
four days and nap time. And,
but again,
what she realized was that
if she was to stop me,
she's got a jerk in the
house. Now, not, not even,
I mean just, just, it just is.
It's just the reality of it.
I just would be really frustrated with
the situation and all I want to do is
just go train because it's part of who
I am and I want to get on the mat and I
want to get better and I want
to, it's very selfish, right?
I mean all of the reasons are
selfish, but that be that, that,
but
the reality is that's,
that's me.
That's me. Yeah, that's me team.
And you can't change your knee. Yeah,
will, we'll, of course, of course.
It's still gonna be you.
But you know,
this is going to sound real obvious and
Cliche, but the whole compromise thing,
when you guys have a bunch of kids,
you got a compromise and don't be like,
hey everyone else in the whole
group. By the way, the kids,
even though you know your wife,
everyone in the whole group,
you guys compromise a factor
of eight out of 10. Me,
I'm just going to compromise the factor
of 0.5 cause I'm still gonna go to Jiu
Jitsu every single day for as
long as I've done it. You know,
do all the things that you've done before.
You have kids, you can't do that. Yeah,
I don't think you can do that.
Yeah, no, you shouldn't do that.
But I am saying yeah and
I did. Yeah. And and sure.
A lot of it because he's not aware.
A lot of time you, you're not saying,
you know what? I know I'm being a
Dick Right now and you know what?
I'm okay with being a Dick Right now.
You know,
and then I share a fault for not
letting me train or whatever. Yeah.
I guess I might not have been the best,
the best husband and let scenario
live and learn and, and it's, it's,
I don't want to say it's good, but when
you have new kids and especially twins,
twins,
it does allow you to kind of
reconcile what's important.
You know,
like let's say every Tuesday you went to
Taco Tuesday or something like that and
drank every Tuesday right before kids,
now you've got twins. I'm like, man,
I'm really how you get
to honestly ask yourself,
is that kind of stuff important now?
No.
Taco Tuesday's not important
compared to kids. Yeah. No,
but you could say time with my friends
is important and all this other stuff,
but the drinking and it just all little,
little detailed things that
you can easily go without.
And in a lot of cases do better without,
but their vices or whatever when you can,
when you have twins or new
kids or just kids in general,
you do get that opportunity to reconcile
what's more important. Yeah. You,
you get to prioritize and execute.
I'm sure for sure.
All right. We haven't, congratulations
twins. It's a big deal. Yeah. No doubt.
I hope their hope,
the names are echo in jeans.
I mean what happened
in the hall.
Yeah.
Jocko knowledge is a powerful
tool to become knowledgeable.
You must ask good questions.
You have advice for asking
good questions. Yeah, I mean,
knowledge is a powerful tool for sure.
A, I mean it's, it's the
master of tools, right?
It's where all your tools come from.
Okay.
Because without knowledge there's nothing,
and you know,
you take that one step further
and really knowledge is,
it's a weapon.
It's the ultimate weapon
in it trumps all other weapons,
right?
Fought is what wins the mind is what wins.
The knowledge is what wins.
And you absolutely,
you,
you, you gain knowledge by
asking questions. Right?
So my advice for asking
questions is pretty simple.
Question everything.
Don't,
don't just accept anything as truth.
Question it all question everything.
I tell my kids when they go to school
to sit in the front of the classroom and
when they, when they, when they don't
understand something that's second,
they don't understand something, just
put your hand right up in there and say,
I don't understand that. I understand
that part. Can you go over that again?
And that's how you need to be in life.
That's how I try to be.
Well, you don't understand a word.
Break out a dictionary and look it up.
Okay?
If you don't understand the concept,
break down the concept until
you do understand it. Vina,
know how something works. Dig into
it until you do know how it works.
Ask every question that comes to mind.
And I'm not saying that you
have to blurt out why, why, why,
why this like a five year
old and everything you see.
But yes,
ask those questions and
learn and most importantly,
question yourself.
Question yourself every day.
Ask Yourself,
Oh,
who am I?
Yeah.
What have I learned?
What have I created?
What forward progress have I made?
Who have I helped?
Yeah.
What am I doing to improve
myself today to get better,
faster, stronger, healthier, smarter?
Ask Yourself,
is this what I want to be?
This is this all I've got this,
this,
everything I can give.
Is this
going to be my life
and do I except that
you got to ask yourself those questions,
those hard questions,
and you've got to answer getting,
answer them truthfully and you
got to realize that all of us,
all of us,
okay,
can do better.
We can be better.
You just got to take that first step
and that first step is when you
begin to ask those questions.
Yeah.
So advice on asking questions,
ask the hard questions
and ask the hard questions of yourself.
Ain't in the answers to those questions
is where you find that path,
the path to progress
and the path to freedom
inside your mind.
And I think that's
all I've got for tonight.
Thanks to all the troopers out
there for tuning in, listening, uh,
spending some time in my mind
with my strange little thoughts.
Appreciate it.
Thanks for sharing your thoughts
with me on the interweb connecting.
It definitely is cool to have everybody
connected with me and giving me feedback,
giving us feedback about what's going
on, supporting the podcast, listening,
downloading, subscribing, reviewing, all
that stuff is very helpful and very cool.
And we got a couple of other things that
we can do that you can do if you want
to support you. Uh, do you want to support
the podcast? So what can they do? Echo,
uh, first thing they can do
if you want, um, when you do
your, your Amazon shopping,
I'm just click through the link on our
website. [inaudible] two websites, uh,
talk about cars.com and Jocko store.com
right. People don't know about that one.
Um, we do have shirts. I
haven't mentioned that before.
We have shirts if you like those,
um,
get some of those and a coffee mug
if you want. If you feel like nn. Um,
you can see we have a Facebook
page now. Okay. facebook.com
and that's that. So people can ask
last question. Longer questions. Yeah,
cause yeah, sometimes it's hard
to ask questions in, um, you know,
140 characters or less.
And actually less than that cause he,
you got to put the Jocko
Willink, you know. Um, so, uh,
the Facebook page is facebook.com/jocko
podcast and you know,
like it and then you can
put your questions there and
once you're those ones and
um,
of course,
good up on it on it.com/jocko,
they support us and support them.
Yeah. And you get 10% off. Boom.
He support you too. Just like that. Um,
for the supplements and a cool
kettlebells and whatnot. Um, yeah,
there it is, the need, then
you got the, you got the
donation thing too, right? Yes.
Yeah. It stress strong requests
for the donation situation. Um,
and I didn't know how to feel about
it at first, but man, yeah. Thank you.
Thank you guys for that. And it is
available to really, yeah, I did it. Yeah.
Yeah. $4 34 cents for 34,
four months comes from,
it's from Jocko. So if you want to donate,
you can donate. Um, and besides, you know,
thanks for all that support. Thanks for
getting the book. Extreme ownership,
you know, hardcover, kindle, audio
book. If you didn't know that,
review it and you know what?
All that stuff is great,
but most importantly,
here's what you needed to do.
Get up and get out of bed in the morning,
shake off,
okay.
That dreariness and that darkness and
clench your fists and go out into the
light and out into the world and get
after it. That's what she needed to do.
So until next time,
this is Jocko and echo
out.